this was locker room talk this is locker  room talk hello how are you hi you know  I'm automatically attracted to beautiful  I just start kissing them it's like a  magnet any when you restore they let you  do it you can do anything grabbed by the  potty I did join she was married when  she was down in Palm Beach I moved on  her and I failed I'll admit it and I  moved on her very heavily in fact I took  her out furniture shopping I moved in  her like a [ __ ] I couldn't get there  and she was married and all of a sudden  I see her she's now got the big phony  box and everything she's totally changed  her look come on Billy don't be shy okay  you're gonna oh you're you're finished  make me a soap store we're ready let's  go good that's good